[Musik]
kernbotschaft von der islam ist die
friedliche zusammenleben zwischen der
mensch das ist für mich kommt
wie kann ich sage die ersten linien
spätestens seit dem 11 september 2001
fällt es vielen schwer das zu glauben
es folgte ein anschlag in madrid mit 200
toten
ein jahr später vier explosionen in
london bilanz über 50 tote vor einigen
monaten dann das massaker in paris gar
nicht zu reden vom islamischen staat und
alten jungen dschihadisten aus dem
westen die via syrien und irak in die
ewigkeit ein rücken wollen
wieso also kommt muss der vermieter
darauf der islam stehe vor allem für das
friedliche zusammenleben
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
gott mit dem wallenden geduldigen geduld
islamisches aus islamischer sicht
verehrten brüder gehört zu den höchsten
tugenden eines moslems geduldige
menschen erreichen ihre ziele durch
standhaftigkeit und austauschen
[Musik]
seit nunmehr 20 jahren beweist diese
geduld und ausdauer im kampf gegen
extremismus und für den dialog der
religionen bei seinen landsleuten vom
balkan hat sein wort gewicht und die
sind die größte gruppe unter den
schweizer muslimen
aber es gebe auch noch viele andere sagt
mimi die solche die nichts wissen
wollten von dialog auch nicht von in
muslimischen dialog da brauche es eben
geduld geduld sollte aber dann habe ich
sauber
es ist eine contact instrument oder wie
denke es ist beste instrument die
schwierigkeiten zu überwinden auch
betrieb das zusammenleben zwischen den
religionen und kulturen halt eine
religionsgemeinschaft wie bei uns weil
bei uns auch gibt es verschiedene leute
aus verschiedenen kontinenten und
sprachen und so weiter wir brauchen
sowieso geduld der wille zum dialog
manifestiert sich in bayern seit 2012 im
bau eines hauses der religionen am
europaplatz sollen fordern muslime
christen juden buddhisten und hindus tür
an tür bieten ein prestige-projekt der
schweizweit und darüber hinaus strahlen
soll
mehmeti ist als imam der moschee
vorgesehen aber das muss nicht allen
muslimen
konservative kreise betonen und
zerstörten im vergangenen herbst gar ein
modell des neuen gotteshauses dass mimi
die in seiner bisherigen moschee im
länggassquartier aufgestellt hatte
[Musik]
mehmedi die sich nicht einschüchtern und
das haus der religionen ist mittlerweile
realität
die bauarbeiten in der moschee sind dank
vieler freiwilliger auf der zielgeraden
schon in einer woche hier das erste
freitagsgebet abhalten
damit alles klappt schaut der persönlich
zum rechten wobei es eine sorte nicht
nur dem gebäude gilt sondern sozusagen
auch dessen inneren werten nämlich den
gläubigen und die entwicklung nicht nur
der spirituellen und ja dieses bestimmte
zeit wie lange sind sie heben der
schweiz aber von einer 19 jahre singen
im beherrschen also perfekt deutsch
sprechen wie einheimischen das ist so
derbe sprache es geht nicht sprache ist
erste element instrument das
zusammenleben mit gibt es viel zeit da
müssen wir vergessen weil sie haben
außerdem religion italien mit anja
niemand gibt es schwierigkeiten und
deswegen denken sie dieses projekt ja
okay die leute würden verkoppeln jetzt
gerade
ok bitteschön einer show muss nicht
aussehen
nein wenn schuhe ausziehen wenn gibt es
eine schöne tipi
es ist keine ritter es ist nicht berlin
gibt es eine klasse hat sich angekündigt
sie wollen mehr erfahren über den
interreligiösen dialog und den islam
sind jetzt befinden eine moschee seit 20
jahren in hinterstoder über die
wirkliche dann immer schöne worte dass
du sagen liebe zwischen den religionen
akzeptanz aber für mich ist praktisch
etwas entwickeln wir miteinander leben
praktisch wie jetzt gerade niemand das
ist mit dieser antwort ist klar man muss
auch mal fünf gerade sein lassen ja eine
richtung mekka meinen sie ja
normalerweise es ist so eine moschee
sollte unbedingt die kriterien erfüllt
oder die vorstellungen und forderungen
aber bei die möglichkeit wenn jetzt
gerade sollte unbedingt eine moschee
gemecker gericht gebracht und besitzt
aber wenn jemand fragt mir zb 100
prozent wie man eben über ungefähre oder
ungefähr umgekehrt wie denke dass ich
noch in 99,9 legten hacker dass sie so
und und es weckt steht auch ein bild vor
augen
die richtung ist die denke es ist
richtig ich denke so und ich denke so
und ich glaube sagen okay es wurde genau
solche aussagen machen ihn für
konservative kreise zu einem roten tuch
um nicht anzuecken schwadroniere er ins
ungefähre dorthin wo er keinem weh tue
und alles beliebig werde vielen
schweizern gefällt dass ein moslem der
sich hier ohne viel aufhebens einfügt
der wieder aufbegehrt noch stört die
sonntagszeitung kürte den japanisch
stämmigen gebürtigen serben der 2005
eingebürgert worden ist jüngst garten
zum schweizer des jahres 2014 firma medi
ist darum klar die eingeschlagene
richtung stimmt er arbeitet auf einen
schweizer islam hin der im gastland
aufgeht
was gefällt ihnen am besten der schweiz
ja ermächtigt die werden demokratie
freiheit und heinz anständigkeit derzeit
reinheit und so weiter
[Musik]
bekenntnisse zu all diesen werten
scheinen not zu tun das ist jedenfalls
der subjektive eindruck viele muslime
die sich offenbar unter eine art
generalverdacht fühlen sind unsere
brüder im ganzes leben nur südwest asien
afrika südamerika nordamerika schneidet
wir sind alle brüder welche richtung ist
andere ist zuerst der menschlich muss
sein
demokratie muss richtig gehen richtig
wie repräsentativ sind solche
bekenntnisse die datenlage ist nun eine
einzige studie des wissenschaftszentrums
berlin hat sich bisher der frage
gewidmet wie wärs europäische muslime
wirklich denken die ergebnisse schrecken
auf 65 prozent sagten zb das ihnen
religiöse regeln wichtiger sein als
säkulare gesetze fast 60 prozent liegen
homosexuelle als freunde ab und 45
prozent glaubten dass man juden nicht
trauen könne
fazit der studie diese befunde
widersprechen ganz klar der oft gehörten
behauptung dass islamische religiöse
fundamentalismus in westeuropa ein
randphänomen ist unklar ist inwiefern
sich diese daten auf die schweiz
übertragen lassen denn die schweiz war
nicht teil der studie und die befragten
hat dann ausschließlich einen türkischen
oder marokkanischen
migrationshintergrund die größte gruppe
unter den schweizer muslimen stellen
indes solche vom bau kann solche wie
midi und der sagt dass der balkan islam
bisher mehrheitlich motorrad praktiziert
worden sei als gläubige menschen aber
wie denn die wir haben eine tradition
wie
können wir miteinander friedliche leben
das sind wichtigtuer und simon gewesen
und heute zu tal und deswegen das was
wir heute auch in der schweiz über ein
gerät demonstrieren oder im alltag der
koran sprich nicht sind die menschen die
ihn zum sprechen bringen sagte der
schwiegersohn des propheten mohammed
bereits im siebten jahrhundert also gibt
es wie bei der bibel um auslegung und
deutungshoheit auch unter schweizer
muslimen mehmedi hat sich bereits 2001
bei den anschlägen auf das world trade
center öffentlich klar positioniert er
versteht den islam als religion des
friedens steht auch im koran gibt es
eine wärs wenn jemand eine person
umgebracht es bedeutet ganze welt
umgebracht gerne magath als genie an so
steht ein text original im koran das
zitat bezieht sich auf den vers 32 tore
5 dort steht deshalb haben wir den
kindern israels verordnet dass wenn
jemand einen menschen tötet ohne dass
dieser einen mord begangen hätte oder
ohne dass ein unheil im lande geschehen
wäre es so sein soll als hätte er die
ganze menschheit getötet
eigentlich nein die rallye sie würden
sagen das gilt auch für muslime der
muslime auch wenn jemand dort der
mandanten die eine ganze welt bedeutet
er wird umgebracht und wenn ein gerät
die ganze welt gerät das ist im bereich
vorbehalten
so oder so auch wer gewalt rechtfertigen
will wird fündig das tötungsverbot als
vers 32 wird zb schon im nächsten vers
wieder aufgehoben
der lohn derer die gegen allah und
seinen gesamten krieg führen und
verderben im lande zu erregen trachten
soll sein dass sie getötet oder
gekreuzigt werden oder dass ihnen hände
und füße wechselweise abgeschlagen
werden oder dass sie aus dem lande
vertrieben werden
und heute zu tage dass es nicht mehr
präsenz und deswegen denke es gibt viele
sache im koran wir sollten nicht
unbedingt oder wir den blick wird mitten
in praxis umsetzen oder und deswegen
dass sie die unterschiede zwischen den
betrieben andere receivern oder
rückständige kräfte mit anderen worten
wo ein wille ist ist auch ein weg
[Musik]
die neue moschee am europaplatz wurde
auf termin fertig und sie ist heute beim
ersten freitagsgebet voll beides hatten
fundamentalisten bis zuletzt
angezweifelt außerdem wurde inzwischen
gerüchteweise bekannt dass sich diverse
konservative immer mit zusammengetan und
eine fatwa ein islamisches
rechtsgutachten erstellt haben
dieses besagt gebetet bei imam mehmet ii
seien ungültig vor gott
mit dieser reaktion diesen leuten müsse
man die hand reichen und miteinander
reden
wie können wir ihm eine konstruktive
dialog unter der muslime
das ist nicht so einfach das ist nicht
so einfach es ist die bereitschaft
sollte von andere seite und hat
sozusagen nicht von unserer seite
dann ist das was fehlt ihm ein gti
moment und deswegen die rückständige
kräften versuchen diese klima zu
missbrauchen und miss haben das betrifft
auch mit der die so genannte fed weiter
soll die anstalten thorberg im emmental
rund 40 prozent der gefangenen sind
muslime das heißt neben dem speiseplan
musste auch die spirituelle betreuung
neu geregelt werden muss der vermieter
ist im kanton bayern mittlerweile zu 50
prozent aus gefängnisseelsorge raum
gestellt die wahl wurde ein taxi kommt
einmal pro woche auf dem thorberg immer
auch mit der situation angemessenen
koran zitaten auf arabisch in alanya
quelle der epidemie
gott vergibt alle sind enten alle sünden
das heißt gibt es keine sünde gott nicht
gibt im gegenteil
es spielt keine rolle was hat getarnt
war oder so weiter weil immer gibt es
als der nati wie möglich so der ausweg
haben und so weiter das ist so
die soll mithelfen dass die gefangenen
diesen ausweg erkennen der kriminalität
abschwören und den weg zurück in die
gesellschaft finden wie ich denke unsere
aufgabe und unsere fliegt er im
gefängnis als er habilitation system
konzept aber dazu gehört auch lagern und
religion
wobei religion und gefängnis auch eine
potenziell gefährliche kombination sein
können
[Musik]
die radikalisierung der attentäter von
paris steht beispielsweise in direktem
zusammenhang mit ihrer zeit in einem
französischen gefängnis der gefahr von
religiöse radikalisierung im
strafvollzug sind sich auch die berner
behörden bewusst thorberg direktor
thomas egger macht keinen hehl daraus
dass er sich nicht zuletzt für eine
zusammenarbeit mit mehmedi entschieden
habe weil dieser als gemäßigte ihm
helfen solle solche tendenzen zu
verhindern und stark in kontakt mit den
verschiedenen seelsorge und der
verschiedenste weltreligion aber hier
tat xii und das ist mehr einhellig
besser wurde das dortige tendenzen
feststellt wurde sie besser bist eine
lange freiheitsstrafe wegen
drogendelikten er ist albaner und nur
mäßig religiös aber trotzdem froh
thermit ist regelmäßige besuche
respekt kommt vor allem respekt und
akzeptanz die grundprinzipien des
menschlichkeit und wenn man respektieren
andere leute ja wenn ihr mann der
respektiert mehr oder keine respekt
zeigt gegenüber den menschen dann er
respektiert auch nicht gott
es spielt keine rolle welche regionen
klar nationalität fahrbahn sprachen
zweiter war ein anschluss wir sind alle
gottes geschont
in der theorie ist man sich einig es
braucht respekt im besten falle
allerdings nicht nur gottes geschöpfe
sondern künftig auch den schweizer
gesetzen gegenüber erneut ortstermin im
haus der religionen dem selbsternannten
leuchtturm in sachen dialogen respekt
und toleranz bietet in jedem zweiten
satz davon und alle finden es gut er
dringend nötig womit man hier schließen
könnte wenn denn klar wäre was damit
genau gemeint ist wo fängt etwa toleranz
konkret an und wo endet sie wie hält es
die man zum beispiel mit den
homosexuellen wenn irgendwie ja man
entscheidet eher wenig inhalte
islamisches konzepts leben oder zum
beispiel entscheidet über homosexualität
und so weiter er gedenke es sollte nicht
mehr kommen in die moschee oder in die
kirche gehen und den worten suchen
eine legitimität zu haben dass sie
irgendwie gleichzeitig finde in der
widerspruch im eine seite
respektiert oder nicht in der lage zu
respektieren die normen religiöse normen
der seite versucht ihn unterstützen wir
wollen dass sich irgendwo widerspruch
ich denke diejenigen sind eben frei
gesellschaft leben sie müssen selber
entscheiden wie sie wollen wie sie
wollen weil am schluss am schluss es
gibt es eine ordnung hat ein richter
staaten haben natürlich auch wenn ich
sie richtig verstehe ein gläubiger
muslim kann nicht homosexuell sein nein
sagen
eine hammer eine gläubige moslem
homosexuell sicher bekommt keine
legitimität von unserer region oder wie
eine segnung und so weiter aber sonst
wie ein moslem lebt immer eine offene
gesellschaft das ist eine private sache
einen monat später wird die moschee im
haus der religionen offiziell eröffnet
mehmedi ist nervös er hat die polizei
aufgeboten regentief er befürchtet
stimmen konservativer kräfte doch es
bleibt alles ruhig
es ist ein tag der schönen worte des
verbindenden der gemeinsamkeiten ein tag
an dem alle am gleichen strick ziehen
schritt für schritt in die richtige
richtung und ja es ist einmal mehr ein
tag ganz im zeichen von dialog respekt
und toleranz der religion muss so
gebrauchen
das dem glück und frieden und harmonie
den menschen dienen so ich verstehe
religion unsere bereit sollte im zug und
der reflektieren die grundprinzipien des
islams zuerst toleranz akzeptanz frieden
harmonie und gleitzeit zusammenleben
ich denke wir als gläubige menschen
müssen wir unsere glaube unsere moscheen
unsere vereinen für menschen und nur
menschen zu dienen das ist unsere
aufgabe es ist unsere pflicht
für solche worte haben in politik und
medien auf eine art podest gehoben
mehmedi der gute moslem eine
projektionsfläche
dabei ist die realität nicht einfach nur
schwarz und weiß
könnte es sein dass es bei allen
religionen selbst in ihren moderaten
auslegungen auch problematische aspekte
gibt darüber muss man reden vielleicht
nicht heute aber künftig der staat bei
haus der religionen haben als symbol für
die offenheit auch einen möglichen ort
wo alle leute ihn gehen können alle
leute sicher austauschen können die
verschiedenen wichtigen religionen
dieser welt an einen ort miterleben
können
und ich denke wenn imam mustafa
prädikant das wort wenigen vorgelebt
werde ich mich ein vorbild ich danke ihm
auch sehr für seine große forschung
bleibt zu hoffen dass der dialog weiter
geht
ein dialog notwendig der auch unbequeme
fragen stellt und diese nicht aus
bequemlichkeit oder politiker
correctness bagatellisiert oder
tabuisiert